et et le vin euh c'est une des grandes
spécialités de du salon de l'agriculture
avec bien sûr le terroir l'Île-de-France
qui est la 3è région française pour
l'agriculture a de quoi réjouir vos
papill gustatives la région est présente
au salon avec son stand terroir et
saveur d'Île-de-France et parmi les
produits à découvrir les fruits et
légumes la viande et les produits
laitiers et je vous le disais à
l'instant le vin nous allons tout de
suite voir ce sujet de Hanne Guillet et
Abdel Judi avec un exemple au blanc
Ménil où l' fabrique du vin blanc le vin
qui aimerait bien entrer aussi par la
grande porte au salon mais qui n'y
parvient pas il est pas encore
commercialisé voyez ce
reportage tout près de l'autoroute au
blancménil un petit vin se fabrique
discrètement
tranquillement tout a commencé derrière
cette porte il y a 15 ans 1300 pieds de
chardonnais sont bichonnés le vigneron
est au petit soin là je suis en train de
tailler ce qu'on appelle la taille
d'hiver afin de préparer la vigne pour
qu'elle puisse débourrer au printemps
les bourgeons qui son qui sont ici voyez
vont grossir ils vont commencer à sortir
de leur de leur coquille il va donner
des sments les fruits et cetera et
ca une vigne municipale soigné comme un
enfant qui grandit le vin n'est pas
encore adulte mais la culture du vin
renaitt dans une île de France qui fut
la plus grande région viticole au 18e
siècle c'est à la fois un vin culturel
et un vin pé que parce que culturel
parce que bon c'est vraiment une
résurrection et un maintien des racines
et un maintien d'une tradition d'un
savoir-faire qui existait et pédagogique
dans la mesure où il va être transmis
aux générations par l'intermédiaire des
écoles qui ont la chance innoui
finalement de venir dans ces vignobles
et de voir très près de Paris et dans
Paris même comment on cultive la vigne
et comment on produit du raisin et
finalement aussi comment on fait du vin
agrume ananas même un petit peu de
mangue
assez marqué son les arômes habituels du
chardonn petit vin introuvable dans le
commerceadministration n'a pas encore
autorisé la vente les anciens de la
commune ont le privilège d'y goûter mais
seulement une fois l'an à l'occasion de
leur
banquier